what's going on guys this is Rob we are
back with sins of sinister the
conclusion so let's get into it because
I'm excited to see how you feel about
the ending because every comic book fan
everywhere is theorizing what the ending
means which I'm really excited to see
what you guys think but what this does
this initially picks up with storm and
the Brotherhood of Newton's with a third
issue now remember the third issue of
storm in the Brotherhood picks up 900
years after the death of storm which he
had that momentary moment where she just
went like beyond omega level and then
died and so what this means is that John
ironfire kind of the second in command
of storm is now the one running the show
now remember his main power is that he
can turn his blood into metal which will
really become important later on down
the line but the other part of this is
that this is all drawn the attention of
Emma Frost now A Thousand Years in the
future Emma Frost has seemingly merged
herself with what she calls the red
diamond but more or less seems to be a
portion of the Crimson gym of sidorak
now there's nothing to indicate that she
is a Harbinger which is to say a version
of the Juggernaut but the fact remains
she is nigh indestructible in this form
and so what she's been doing or what she
is doing at the moment is scouring the
space ways looking for sinister because
previously she thought he was dead but
when she found out he was alive she
realized it's only a matter of time
before he gets his hands on one of the
moras downloads everything that had
happened or takes all the information of
the last 1 000 years puts it into Amora
and then kills her because remember the
nature of Maura mctaggart's power is
that every time she dies the timeline
resets but she remembers everything that
happened over the course of her life so
that's kind of the goal the Sinister has
it's a giant experiment right that's
literally all it is now what we end up
doing here is we pick up with Sinister
directly basically at the headquarters
of the Brotherhood because remember
where the Brotherhood is located they
guard all the Clones of Mora so that's
been where sinister's been trying to get
to the entire time now the other thing
about this is that if you guys recall in
the early days of the X-Men Comics one
of the things we learned is we had what
were called the five basically whenever
the X-Men want to resurrect somebody
from the dead they need five particular
mutants in order to do it what we end up
finding out here is that the mutants
that Resurrect The Dead are basically
different now A Thousand Years in the
future than they were in the past but
the process Still Remains they can
resurrect people all they needed was the
ability to pull it off kind of a
resurrection egg of sorts and Sinister
presents the Brotherhood with that and
they do exactly what you would expect
them to do which is resurrect storm but
there's a caveat to this right it's one
of the coolest things about it as a
caveat because when I saw this my
thought was okay so like storm coming
back I kind of get where they're coming
from right death doesn't mean the same
anymore storm does return but remember
the second part of the Resurrection
process when it came to the X-Men is
they would always back up the memories
of the various mutants who died so when
they were resurrected Jean Gray or Hope
Summers or whoever they were using would
telepathically put those memories in
their head there's no one here to do
that so yes storm is back but storm does
not remember the full totality of her
powers she doesn't remember how she died
she doesn't remember anything about her
past life so she's basically brand new
to the world now it's kind of a funny
thing here because as this happens Emma
Frost makes her move and sends all of
her forces directly to the Citadel of
the Brotherhood and again Chimera is the
name of the game merging different
mutant Powers into a singular mutant and
that's why you have like super strong
versions of Cyclops that are gigantic in
size that can fire massive energy beams
and they're just ridiculously strong all
that kinds of stuff and so the reality
here is the forces of Emma are Next
Level because not only that Emma Frost
actually allows herself to be placed
inside of what is an effect a giant
Diamond robot right like she's colossal
in size so then she launches her attack
and because of her telepathy combined
with her indestructible form she
basically just starts crushing everybody
at the Citadel now it's a really cool
moment when this happens so the reason
why is because John iron fire leads the
attack against Emma Frost forces but
then at that moment because a doombot
had survived or we covered that in the
last video that we did that Sinister
rips off the hands of one of the Doom
bots which as you guys know basically
have like these little lasers that can
shoot out of them by all standard is a
measurement he effectively has a gun and
so when this happens storm basically
uses their powers or uses the kind of
intuition that comes with what you could
call the knowledge of her powers Taps
into what she's capable of and then
launches an attack against Emma Frost
now for the most part she's relatively
successful this is also because of the
fact that Korra who has the ability to
amplify the powers of other people
boosts the powers of storm we saw that
in the second issue of storm in the
Brotherhood which is how storm became
beyond omega level in the first place
the same thing happens here but the
difference is that instead of storm
using magic like she did in the second
issue what she does is it shows shows a
pure display of what she's capable of
now this is a huge moment right it's
very easy to forget and it's very easy
to lose focus of how significant this is
but what storm does is she uses her
power over the lightning to control the
electrons within the structure of Emma
Frost this giant robotic body and then
detonates the whole thing in what's
basically a nuclear explosion now it
does kill storm but the big moment
behind this and the reason why this is
so important is because it shows that
storm can control the electrons of any
object around her due to her ability to
tap into lightning now this is
comparable to like Jubilee from the
X-Men there are those of you guys who
don't know what I'm talking about
there's a comic where Emma Frost I if I
remember correctly was Emma Frost had
seized control of Jubilee and then
realized when she makes those little
firework type things that she's actually
detonating matter and that if Jubilee's
power were pushed to his absolute limits
she could quite literally detonate
matter on the subatomic level and just
create nuclear explosion out of nowhere
she could blow up a whole world if she
wanted to or even make a star go
supernova we haven't really seen
anything to indicate that she's getting
to that point but that's the potential
of what she has storm is very much in
that way this is an instance where
Marvel is teasing what storms capable of
and we may very well see that at some
future point in time but of course storm
basically perishes so she was here just
kind of for a moment long enough to
defeat Emma Frost but in this momentary
distraction Sinister uses the gun from
the Doctor Doom doombot and then fires
it at John iron fire and shoots him in
the head and so with John ironfire out
of the picture seemingly the entire
landscape is clear right Emma Frost is
defeated her forces will launch a
counter-attack but the reality is
they're not overly concerned about it
what Sinister is concerned about is that
with Emma Frost defeated someone's going
to step up and take her place and when
they do they're going to come after the
attacker clones as well so in
reality they're they're really on a kind
of timeline here the other thing that
complicates the this is access to where
the Clones are located is blocked and
there's seemingly no way to get to it
now one of the funny things about this
is Sinister talks about in the message
that was left to him by Destiny that
there was a kind of indication that
Destiny had set in motion a set of
events that would allow Sinister to gain
access to the clones by quite literally
destroying the door this coincides with
the moment that we covered in the last
video when we ended up finding out that
in the early days when Sinister was
basically taking over everything when
the X-Men were coming under semester's
control that they fired Juggernaut into
space literally out of a cannon in order
to destroy Thanos because remember once
the Juggernaut starts moving nothing can
stop him and being fired at Thanos like
a gun would blow a hole right through
him and that's exactly what it did right
it killed Thanos on the spot but what
this also did is it just sent Juggernaut
careening through space speeding up
going faster and faster right just
slingshotting off of stars and different
things like that the this is what we
talked about in the last video it's
Destiny playing the long game as a
precognitive she can see the future and
so even though a thousand year
prediction isn't the most solid
prediction when it comes to Destiny
every so often it is exactly right right
literally the Juggernaut comes flying
through punches Galactus in the head who
had shown up here being possessed by all
the powers of the Ghost Rider again we
covered that in the last video make sure
you guys check the comments you'll find
a link to the Sims of sinister playlist
you can get caught up on everything and
then in turn like punches a hole
directly through the door where they
where the mores are being located that
gives them the interest now the other
version the girl that you see here in
like the white outfit with the blonde
hair that is Amore mctaggard but it's a
robot right it's not an actual Morris so
she doesn't have an X Gene right so if
you were to kill her nothing would
happen here but the thing about this is
that we end up finding out that John
iron fire actually survived and the
reason why what he did here and it's
probably the most comic book logic thing
ever right the biggest MacGuffin ever
because he has the ability to turn his
blood it into metal that before going
into a battle which is a pretty smart
thing he does exactly that he just like
protected his inner working so you
basically have like flesh and Bone veins
all that kind of stuff and then now his
blood is basically metal it was a layer
of protection against the shot the
Sinister fired so that's how John iron
fire lived here and so what kind of
fight breaks out between the two of them
but it's basically just buying time for
more McTaggart to get in there the
problem is that while more McTaggart is
supposed to gain access to all the other
moral clones she's supposed to clear the
way if there's any resistance for
Sinister the problem with this is that
her immediate response is I need to
destroy these clones but Sinister wants
to take the information he has
downloaded into the Clones so that when
one of them dies the timeline resets and
all the way back at the very beginning
at year zero before everything happens
Sinister can extract the information and
then basically know where he went wrong
so when he repeats his experiment trying
to take over the entirety of the
universe he knows where he missteps and
he can correct those Stakes the problem
with this is that in the absence of Emma
Frost Hank McCoy Beast who is basically
assumed control of her forces contacts
Charles Xavier but Xavier also being in
control here right being just a Villain
at this point in time starts to realize
it's a chance for opportunity so he sees
his control of Hank McCoy seizes control
of everybody in just like this immediate
area and then quite literally makes a
planet unto himself Professor Xavier of
the X-Men becomes a whole world and then
he just starts traveling directly to the
Citadel where more mctaggard and all
those different clones are being held
now once you have Jon and them who
realize what's going on John ironfire
has this genius idea right he literally
conjures this energy dagger and then
slices his forehead right and what he
does is as the blood comes out he
controls it and turns it into a helmet
of Magneto which basically blocks the
telepathic abilities of Charles Xavier
it's one of the smartest moves that I've
seen from his character like I mean it's
not to say he's dumb but it's a genius
idea and so what ends up happening here
is that Sinister kind of pleads with
John iron fire and saying look I get
that you guys as part of the Brotherhood
all that kind of stuff your soldiers
Warriors and having an honorable death
is the way you want to go and so on and
so forth but you don't really want to
die here more so than that you do not
want Xavier to kill all of us kill one
of the moiras reset the timeline and
then he's in control right so we have to
find a way to defeat Xavier and only you
can do it but you need more power and
because blood is literally the source of
your power I can inject you with a
sample of Iceman which will basically
allow you to amplify your abilities by
producing more water vapor blood is 70
percent water so you can basically
create more blood is it comic book logic
absolutely like I mean there's nothing
about this this logical or reasonable
like it's just a thing that's being done
for the purpose of telling the story but
it's amazing because literally this guy
just like uses this injection Khan
measures on like just this insane kind
of like structure right this metal form
he looks like a devil version of Magneto
he looks like a beast and then he just
charges at Xavier right like the whole
planet of Xavier and he's able to kind
of punch a hole through him to a degree
but in reality it's just a giant fight
between the two so while John iron fire
and Xavier are fighting that Sinister
takes off to the to the Clone lab and
then tries to find a way to stop this
robot version of Maura McTaggart but the
reality here is he kind of strikes a
deal with her it says look this is like
if if I don't do this right like if I do
not take this information on what I've
learned and download it into one of the
Morris then what will happen is history
will repeat itself I'll make the same
mistakes the same screw-ups and this
will just be a giant 1 000 year time
Loop over and over and over again if I
download this information it'll be a way
to break the cycle and I will literally
tell myself do not pursue this godhood
do not do that and so ultimately this
robot version of Moira lets him get away
with it and so in turn he basically goes
in and tries to destroy one of these
more mctaggarts but in the process of it
as he's downloading this information he
starts to come to this Revelation maybe
he can be God right maybe he can be just
like some astronomically powerful person
but in shutting down like and destroying
one of these Morris it basically wipes
out the Galaxy and everybody in it right
it wipes out the whole universe it
doesn't really blink the timeline out of
existence and here's the reason why
because of the fact the timeline doesn't
go away this is basically Marvel telling
us this is now an alternate reality the
fact that this has happened means it
always will happen right like this is
always going to take place Sinister can
try to change it and maybe he will but
the fact that all of this has happened
before and the fact that he's even
sending information back into the past
to prevent it from taking place it means
this universe has to happen now the
funny thing about this is that in this
moment Sinister himself seems to kind of
transcend and he actually takes off and
tried to tries to form a kind of
dominion right literally basically sees
control of time and space but what he
finds out when he gets there when he
kind of transcends is that somebody beat
him to the punch that seemingly a
Sinister Dominion has already been
created one of the other sinisters
transcended time and space they exist
Beyond everything and so even if there
is an attempt by Sinister to kill one of
the Mars and reset the timeline that
there is seemingly a Sinister out there
that has already seized control of
everything and everything is happening
in the universe is now happening because
of their whim that's the implication
there's nothing to say that that's the
case it's sinister's hypothesis is what
he believed happened but at the end of
the day we don't necessarily know for
sure and so here's the kicker to this
right like when Sinister comes back he
realizes somebody did beat him to the
punch there's seemingly no way to fix
everything John iron fire reappears
after having presumably killed Xavier
pissed off of the fact that Sinister
basically wiped out the entirety of all
life Across the Universe John ironfire
kills Sinister on the spot God and then
we jump back right like literally we
jump back to year zero right now exactly
how this jump back to year zero happens
not entirely sure it could just be a
cascading effect it could be that like
the destruction of all life across the
across the universe is kind of the first
stage in what is an effect the reset of
the timeline the reason I say that is
that in previous instances in the X-Men
comics in Marvel we never really saw how
the process takes place Emma Frost dies
and then you just jump back to the very
beginning of everything right we don't
actually see how that process unfolds so
this may just be part of the whole thing
but of course jumping back to year zero
right the moment in which Sinister
decides to make the decision to start
putting his own gene into the various
X-Men as they're being resurrected in
order to seize control that as he's
scanning one of the myras he finds a
thousand years worth of information
stored inside of her and so when he
downloads the information everything
blows up right everything just goes nuts
all of a sudden and you basically have
the real Amore McTaggart who shows up
here and kind of spills the beans and
that's she had seemingly died alongside
everything else and so what this kind of
implies here this is one of the theories
that's circulating out there what this
seems to imply is that the the white
suited Maura McTaggart was not actually
a robot it was the real Amora McTaggart
the entire time because remember she's
Immortal you can kill her through any
conventional means but she'll never die
of natural causes she'll stay youthful
forever so that seems to be who this
actually was so when she in effect
actually reset the timeline that gets us
to where we are right now but the kicker
about all this is more McTaggart
basically tells Sinister everything that
was going on that when you had mother
righteous write an alternate version of
sinister or kind of a different version
of sinister in the future who was trying
to find a way to download information
and then reset the timeline so she could
be in control all that stuff that
everything popped off there but the
reality of what she says here is that
she watched a Sinister had basically
tried to achieve godhood and then in
turn came to a profound realization that
somebody had beat him to the punch and
the information that was sent back to
the past was exclusively that there's no
Grand amount of information that shows
the mistakes he made how he could have
created things differently where he
could have fixed everything that's not
the case right it's just the information
that ultimately somebody beat him there
he never gets to attain godhood the way
that he hoped he had and so what Maura
McTaggart does is she wipes out all the
Clones of herself now the X Gene was
neutralized so basically the Clones are
destroyed but there's no X Gene to reset
the timeline so it's just like killing
mannequins effectively and so with all
that being done suddenly Rasputin 4
appears out of nowhere right now
Rasputin 4 was basically a creation of
sinister in the sins of sinister future
right like in that timeline and so she
was initially his ally but then once she
realized he wanted to wipe out the whole
universe and kind of reset everything
she turned against him her arriving here
is basically an instance of a character
from an alternate reality appearing in
the main Marvel Universe I told you this
would probably happen they would
probably totally end up bringing people
from alternate realities or from the
sins of sinister timeline into the main
Marvel Universe and it's cool for what
it is right but what this also shows
here is that mother righteous this
alternate clone of sinister is still
alive and well right I mean she hasn't
become the mother righteous who's
villainous and sins of sinister and all
that kind of stuff she's still alive and
doing her thing right all those
different clones of sinister are still
there the the theory that's circulating
around out here is that the version of
sinister that achieves godhood right
Dominion hood is actually mother
righteous because there's like this
whole wing of a library that just kind
of appears out of nowhere right like
basically altering reality exclusively
from other righteous and in fact all the
books basically seem to be dedicated to
her it's like this future version of her
who would achieve godhood kind of
reaching out and saying I'm doing this
for you right this is who you become one
day again that's just a theory that's
circulating around we don't definitively
know but what we do know is that
following her capture of sinister
Rasputin basically shows up here and
effectively meets Kitty Pride and the
other members of The Quiet Council now
what ends up happening is that she kind
of spills the beams to what's going on
but also presents mother righteous as
the person that was quote unquote the
Savior right the one that basically
saved everybody saved the future of the
whole nine yards now mother righteous is
manipulative exactly how this transpires
we don't know right because as far as
we're aware mother righteous as she
exists now in the X-Men Comics has no
knowledge of what will happen over the
course of the next 1 000 years when you
have the whole sins of sinister timeline
unfolding we don't know right all we
really know is that she's just kind of
here and she is a clone of like the
original Sinister and she's been
operating for the last few hundred years
and that's it that's all we know about
her character but she basically puts
herself forward as a person who is kind
of the savior of existence but one of
the things that happens is that when
Rasputin Force fills the beans on what's
going to happen over the course of the
next 1 000 years as a result of sinister
basically putting his genes inside all
the different X-Men that are being
cloned is that the X-Men come to the
realization Sinister is the greatest
threat among them now the funny thing
here is that because Sinister as he
stands now was given information about
you know from his future self about how
some version of him out there achieved
godhood he tries to tell the X-Men there
is a Sinister out there manipulating
everything there's a Sinister out there
controlling everything manipulating
everything it's not me you have to
believe me but because of his villainous
past as well as what he's supposed to be
doing over the course of the next 1 000
years and sends a Sinister none of the
X-Men believe it none of them believe
anything he's saying so they ultimately
confine him to the pit the other caveat
to this is that in order to ensure that
Sinister has not already started his
scheme they have to quote unquote purify
the X-Men Gene which means scan them and
make sure nobody is influenced by
sinister's genes but because Emma Frost
and Xavier and these guys are leaders of
the quiet Council and because they're so
powerful and in that future they're the
ones who go nuts and basically conquer
the entirety of the universe that what
they do is they voluntarily confine
themselves to the pit now this kind of
seems to be manipulation at the hands of
mother righteous to a degree and that's
the other part of this theory that
mother righteous is the one who does
achieve godhood because she's the only
one who shows up here and she's the only
one who says in order to ensure that
sinister's influence is no longer here
in the rest of the X-Men we have to
confine the choir Council you guys know
it's what's best for the for the mutant
Community she's clearing the landscape
of any threats she's clearing the
landscape of the most powerful telepaths
she's clearing the landscape of Hope
Summers who's instrumental in being able
to revive any X-Men who die which means
now that an X-Men is dead they stay dead
right there's no way to bring them back
right she's removing any threats to her
potential attempt to seize power of not
just curricula itself but even the world
as a whole because she is a straight up
villain that's kind of where everybody
is leaning to here so again because of
this realization the entrepreneur can
find the pit and seemingly this stage is
set for mother righteous to seize
control as the newest version of
sinister and ultimately basically repeat
the processes since the Sinister and
effectively come out on top but with
that being said guys let me know what
you guys think about this down in the
comments section it's a really wonky
final issue thank you all for watching
and I will catch you all later
peace